so you wanted to see us ah yes I did  Russell Wilson bad news fans aren't  playing as you guys in Madden on xbox  one now as your agent / best friend no I  best friend just just go out there and  connect with Xbox Live community and get  your popularity back up I win great game  Julia I just crushed Russell Wilson a  matted get my place hmm sweepers that's  how it's done acceptable drums back  strip seegmiller really guys it's so  easy to connect on xbox live what's the  issue man you guys are overthinking it  mmm nice play Delores that don't school  nomination son see ya y'all need to work  on your people skills play together on  the fastest gaming Network get the new  xbox one ass